reine de la nuit c'est pas vraiment un
titre teams qui m'emballe j'ai toujours
dit la restructuration ça veut dire
qu'un canon la crise la chanson c'est
une chanson mais ça fait reine d'un jour
quoi je crois qu'une grande une grande
hôtesse je suis une femme d'idées je les
applique comment je pourrais violations
sur de travail je suis en permanence
devant je dors très peu juste en trois
heures et le reste du temps je n'arrête
pas de penser vous en foutez de ce qu'on
peut dire de vous à moi alors je vais
vous dire
ils peuvent dire tout ce qu'ils veulent
alors que yann baudet orange rien mais à
seulement touché face
deux choses qui sont chez moi essentiel
alors là je vais carrément avec le poids
donc je suis plus le cas dans lesquels
je me suis belle ville
qu'est ce qu'il faut pas s'épuiser au
lave mais le nez sans seulement j'ai
jamais connu la pologne mais sauf une
fois mais quelles sont les limites à ne
pas d'insultés antisémites ou anti les
racistes je ne supporte pas je suis
sévère contrairement à ce qu'ont pensé à
mon attitude comme samarante je fais
très attention à ce que disent les gens
liés à ce qu'ils font j'ai cette
facilité de les juger très vite c'est un
bon c'est vrai et quelquefois c'est
agréable mais quelquefois c'est pas
grave c'est pas toujours bon de savoir
tout de suite à qui on a affaire parce
que si on lève beaucoup de choses et
puis dans le fond qu'est ce qu'on en a à
[ __ ] c'est vrai mais franchement je
crois que je suis une fille naturelle je
suis resté ce que j'étais comme j'étais
enfant moi je crois pas ce qu'il ya de
plus important dans la vie c'est ne
jamais oublier d'où on vient et qui on
est
ce que tout le monde est pareil
on dit la chance d'être épargné par la
maladie par les choses les plus graves
et qu'on peut les surpasser c'est
formidable comment vous avez fait pour
toujours tous surpassés
c'est du passé la guerre je suis passé
beaucoup de choses
j'étais sûr pas si basse qu'il fallait
les surpasser et surtout je crois que on
peut pas figé les gens de ces problèmes
et les emmerder en moi je suis pas du
tout comme ça je suis très verrouillé là
dessus j'aime bien montrer que mon côté
gay la solitude je connais et la
solitude contrairement à ce qu'on pense
quand on est positif ce n'est pas un
malin
parce qu'on ne peut pas vivre tout le
temps de la manière dont moi j'ai vécu
le qu'est-ce que je n'ai pas eu je n'ai
pas une famille
j'avais un fils extraordinaire marquée
plus là qui était un personnage que
toute la presse connaît pas ce que
c'était un grand journaliste aussi et
ils étaient bas il était comme moi le
même caractère c'est à dire il ne me
voulaient que pour lui et moi
j'appartiens à tout le monde et moi je
voulais appartenait à tout le monde et
on ne peut pas je ne me rendais pas
compte que je faisais du mal je ne me
rendais pas compte d'une vraie jalousie
que lui devait être le premier après je
pouvais faire ce que je souhaitais le
même temps que j'étais en train de
parler avec des gens et qu'il arrivait
je fais pas planter les gens comme c'est
à dire ah je vous présentais mon fils
d'abord il détestait que je tue ce qui
était le fils de sa compté pour vous
il ya pas de le jour que ça ne compte
pas
on peut pas toujours rires
on sait les fautes qu'on a fait et est
volontairement pas volontairement c'est
très difficile à expliquer pourquoi
j'ai manqué tellement de choses je
voulais tellement j'ai fait je faisais
fête est un moment donné c'est pas une
question d'âge c'est une question
vraiment de moment il ya un moment
douloureux et on se dit je suis pas dit
ça j'ai pas dit ça j'ai pas fait ça se
fait ça et on s'en veut
mais d'un autre côté
souvent je faisais les choses et je
savais qu'il faisait mal mais je reste
sur mes positions lui aussi
un jour il m'a accueilli comme ça
l'aéroport moi avec mes valises
magnifique donnerai mon chauffeur
j'ai vu le père de sabo une salopette un
trip qui m'a dit vous voulez vous que je
porte vos valises c'était lui
c'était une leçon
c'était une leçon pour me dire qu'il y
manquait d'argent que ça fait huit ans
qu'on se parle et plus
et ça c'est inadmissible
la quel est votre rêve aujourd'hui
résume
et plus qu'inquiète de m'amuser de faire
du bien d'être d'être bien dans ma peau
d'être
vous savez moi je suis partie de ces
femmes qui
qui je joue même pas la bataille mon
père était un joueur terrible verges et
il a dû injecter une dose de tout ça
donc j'en ai pas besoin je vais beaucoup
d'alcool ou non pas que jamais mais je
crois que je crois surtout qu'il était
un homme très drôle
c'est vrai que quand je le juge est jugé
très mal vous savez c'était le vrai faux
lac
avec son accent yiddish nous embrasser
sur la bouche hors jeu c'était tout ça
me déplaisait
aujourd'hui je vends des portes ouvertes
et quand j'ai écrit le premier livre je
pensais pas de mal de lui j'en ai fait
un héros tous les ans tous les jeunes
ils usaient leurs parents pourquoi ne
pas faire croire que oui oui pourquoi
pas moi je dormais sur les banquettes
dans les casinos dans les bistrots je
l'accompagnais partout où je suis devenu
noctambules comme ça il y avait une
usine de confiture et on avait acheté la
confiture à 5 heures du matin on rentre
à midi ils font rentrer parce qu'il est
arrêté au poste de police qu'ils
jouaient des jeux clandestins enfin bref
tout était rigolo en fait tout était
rigolo plus tard pas sur le moment avec
mon père c'est des regrets de
ne suis pas connu ma mère
elle nous a toujours raconté qu'elle
nous avait abandonné nous a jamais
abandonné par les pales france elle
était être surpassé les frontières sans
papiers il lui a dit qu'elle allait
l'argent ni l'âge abriter la rejoignent
en est réussi avec clip c'est tout il a
dit ce qu'il a voulu on a surtout après
sa mort et
quand j'ai voulu la connaître elle nous
en argentine moi j'avais un club en
argentine
elle a essayé de m'appeler de droit j'ai
raccroché
les ajouts ne soit pas bien ça j'ai
regretté